Barry smith is a professor of philosophy
and director of the Institute of
Philosophy as well as the founder of the
Center for the study of this census,
which pioneers collaborative research
between philosophers,
psychologists,
and neuroscientists is published on self
knowledge,
linguistic knowledge,
consciousness,
the emotions,
taste and smell,
and there's appeared frequently on BBC
radio including the writing and
presenting of a four part series for the
World Service called the mysteries of
the brain is also the wine columnist for
prospect magazine buries me.
Thank you very much for coming on under
the skin.
Pleasure to be here.
This is a big subject to discuss the
relationship between the senses and
consciousness.
The sense is,
I suppose it's these are the avenues to
experience these represent who we are,
but it seems from even a cursory
examination of your work,
there is much misunderstanding about the
framework of the centers.
Can you talk to us a little about that
note?
I believe the I aristotle and idea that
there are about five.
Yeah,
I mean I think you're right.
The sensors are our closest contact with
the world.
You know,
that's how we know where we are,
so we see things in front of us here,
things are in touch with people quite
literally taste and smell,
and we've for a long time thought we
just have five senses that whatever
we're perceiving,
it's got to be either seeing or hearing,
smelling,
tasting,
touching,
and we get that from aristotle who told
us we had these five senses.
And it's strange because if you talk to
neuroscientists as I do know,
you ask him any senses of we got,
they say anywhere between 22 and 33,
you know,
many senses.
And it's kind of funny that we've given
up aristotle's view.
There were only five elements that made
up the whole of the world.
Uh,
we,
we've rejected that physics has done
away with it,
but,
but the idea that we have five senses
has prevailed and that's what people
think of when they think about
themselves.
The thing I've just got five,
we go out now and we ask people in the
street,
they'll say five sensors.
Sure.
Lack of a safari.
You sort of think elephants,
giraffes,
lions.
So sight,
smell,
taste,
hearing,
touch.
So like bit beyond that,
we say,
what is,
what is the panoply of sense neglected?
Well,
let's just,
just think of a few more sense of
balance.
If that goes off,
you know all about it.
I mean the world starts spinning so it's
going to affect,
you know,
how your vision is behaving and your
sense of balance is clearly important
and on all the time if things are going
well,
uh,
if people are home,
wants to do this,
you know,
try standing up and standing on one leg
and they'll wobble at all there.
Okay?
Now try closing your eyes and standing
on one leg and you'll find it's much
harder.
I know.
You'll know that your sense of balance
is actually made up of three sentences.
Sight,
proprioception,
which is their sense we have of our own
body from the inside.
If you close your eyes,
now you know where your feet are on your
hands are without having to see them or
touch them.
You just feel where they are,
but it's not by not by touch.
So that's your proprioception.
That's knowing where your body is in
space,
so that sense plus site plus these
beautiful little ear canals you have,
so you've got ear canals pointing up and
down,
backwards and forwards and side to side,
and that tells you whether in a left
you're going up or whether you're
rushing forward and that combines with
site and with a sense of your body to
give you your sense of balance.
Am I lying down to my standing upright?
My tipping over incredibly complex
mechanisms which boundary our sense of
self sensory deprivation.
Then I suppose is an interesting area
because it limits how we encode it.
Limits experience and if the sensory
deprivation tank or people that are
blind from birth or don't have hearing
that well,
that that makes a big,
big difference.
So,
so the funny thing about the senses is
there a little bit narcissistic.
They tell you about the world,
but they also tell you about you.
So they're giving you a sense of how you
are and what's going on with you.
So even as we speak now,
we are making sounds that have a echo
from the wall or from the table,
the floor,
and that's telling us kind of how much
noise we're producing.
But if you've ever been,
as I'm sure you have as,
as a,
uh,
as an artist who works in sound,
if you've ever been in an anechoic
chamber where there's absolutely no
echo,
it's frightening.
You make assigned nothing comes back and
you actually feel you're almost dead.
There is a feeling that you've,
you've kind of landed in some weird,
strange world and the,
and the thing is that your brain is
paying attention to the,
to the sounds you make in the world.
So as you walk along the pavement,
obviously your feet are making a noise,
but you don't realize because you're not
paying attention to it,
that the brain has recording that
signed.
So colleagues of Mine and at Adora and
affiliate Darwalla created these
beautiful things.
Sonic shoes.
So you're wearing a,
you're wearing a kind of flip flop and
their little sensors in it and it's
sending information up to headphones.
And as you walk,
they can make your footsteps sound
heavier,
louder,
or make them sound lighter.
And the interesting thing is that
people's bodies behave completely
differently when you make the sign from
their own feet signed heavy,
they slouched the lean forward,
they look as though it's a real effort.
And when you turn the frequency up high,
so you just get this sort of light sign
from the feet.
People start leaping,
they actually start moving more happily
in space and you think that's
incredible.
You didn't realize that your brain and
your body are trying to make everything
fit together.
You're getting signals from signed,
from touch,
from,
from smell,
from everything.
And the brain is trying to put all that
information together and to see what's
going on out there.
And how are things with me are
experiencing realities,
obviously determined by the senses.
What are these studies,
uh,
that,
demonstrate that if you're asked to
answer social political questions,
for example,
should there be more or less immigration
that your response may vary if there's a
presence of an unpleasant smell in the
room?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Well,
that stuff's interesting because smell
is the most neglected sense and if you
asked people,
I'm sure if I asked you now and you
think,
which sense of the five would you give
up?
You know,
if you had to,
you're forced to.
People always say,
I give up sense of smell.
They think not so important,
but they're wrong.
They're actually fundamentally wrong.
Sense of smell is very important.
Is that the oldest one?
Yeah,
I think it.
I think it is.
And and paramecium bacteria in our,
in a jar have got receptors that respond
to orders.
So you know from the simplest animal up,
smell is important.
Now what?
Why?
Why is smell important?
Well,
it's,
it's used to give you a sense of danger.
If there's smoke predators,
if you are an animal,
we use it for attraction.
So it turns out that you are most
attracted to people who smell suggests
that their immune system is further away
from yours.
So we're,
we actually are,
are not attracted to people who smell is
going to indicate that there are too
close to us genetically,
that their immune system is too close to
us.
So you know,
you might find yourself talking to
somebody and you think,
oh,
you know,
they are very attractive,
they're very lovely,
very beautiful,
but if they smell wrong,
there's nothing you can do,
there's nothing you can do to over come
that.
And on the other hand you might have
people you suddenly feel very attracted
to and you wonder why.
And it could be love at first smell.
So your sense of smell is,
is about attraction.
It's also about recognizing your kin.
If we give you a tee shirt,
a that your infant has had on,
you will know it's yours.
You will know that an equally,
you know,
the infant will be able to tell that
that's the mother there in front of it,
from the sense of smell more so at first
than from sight.
And smell is also one of those things
that tells us that everything is okay.
So you no longer smell your own home.
Everybody else's homes got smell but
yours doesn't wise.
That's kind of funny right around this
unite,
like while you're telling me they stuff,
giving you ideas.
Well and also reminding me of stuff.
Like what?
Like I remember as I'm sure everybody
does when you're a kid and you go around
other people's houses,
you smell it,
smell of fish fingers in.
So it was a beef burgers and you know,
you remember your friend's houses and
you're a member.
You're relative sizes,
you know how they smell and you and yet
you think yours doesn't.
That's funny.
So what's happened is that you're so
used to the smell of your own home.
You've switched that off,
but it doesn't mean it doesn't mean it's
gone entirely because if you go into
your home and say,
oh,
someone's been in here,
someone's been smoking,
or did I leave the rubbish out?
You know,
so you're on it like that.
So we're touching upon,
I suppose to the idea that the sensory
realm is establishing norms that we
neglect information once we've judged it
to be standardized.
Yeah,
I think,
I think in particular that's right with
smell,
because you might think that smells job
is to detect change.
If nothing's changed,
leave it alone.
Why?
Why put the brainpower into maintaining
a permanent of factory landscape the way
we do with a visual landscape?
Why do that?
If it's not checkers?
Still Beef Burgers,
beef burgers,
still slightly pointless data.
That's ketchup.
I don't need to bother,
right?
But also remember that when we talked
about food,
your sense of smell is actually the most
important sense for getting flavor from
food,
so without smell,
they experience of gastronomy or
cuisines.
Nothing is nothing.
In fact,
all you get,
all you can get if you had your a nose
clip on and we can put a pinch your nose
tightly shot and try eating things.
All your gets what the tongue provides
salt,
sweet,
sour,
bitter,
savory.
That's it,
and yet you can taste cherry,
pineapple,
mango,
strawberry.
You don't have strawberry receptors on
your tongue.
That's all coming from smell.
So if we took your sense of smell away,
that's all lost and you often get
patients going to the doctor,
certainly an older age and they say,
I've lost my sense of taste.
Now a good doctor will say,
put your tongue out.
Here's a bit of lemon juice,
or here's a bit of salt to taste that,
oh yeah,
taste that,
but that's all I can taste,
and now they realize how much of what
they thought was taste is actually due
to smell.
It also seems very that the sensory
realm,
it is highly collaborative and this is
analogous to what we're learning about
neurology and psychology.
I suppose that it's not like this is the
bit of the brain that deals with fear.
This is the bit of the brain.
The centers are collaborating to create
a perception of reality in ways that
with them we may have imagined they
really
are so,
so.
So that's the second big thing.
You know,
one thing is giving up five,
many more than five,
and the second thing is saying their
senses are massively interacting.
You almost never have an experience.
That's just in one sense modality.
In fact,
the arts is the place where we think
that happens.
You go to a gallery and you think,
oh,
I'm just using my eyes,
but in fact you're aware of the
acoustics in the gallery.
That's why if you're in a very big room
with a high ceiling,
it's very different from being in a kind
of small,
tight space,
looking at the same painting.
You're also aware of the smell of the
gallery.
I'm coming back smell one of my favorite
galleries where I grew up in Glasgow,
a art gallery and Museum Kelvin Grove,
and when it went in for a 40 million
pound refit and it closed for many
years,
the Glaswegians all said,
don't change the smell.
Don't change the smell because they had
been there as kids.
They had gone back as adults.
They had taken their own kids and it was
that familiar smell of old stone and
furniture Polish,
which they wanted because it was part of
their childhood.
It's part of their memory and so the
sensors,
the sensors do make up the world.
They don't work separately,
but let me show you some of the
interactions.
I mean there are weird ones,
so there are odors and shampoo that make
your hair feel softer.
Who Knew?
So that sort of green apple you
sometimes get in shampoos.
It will sensitize,
touch at the end of your fingers to make
everything seem really soft and squeaky
and lovely.
There are interactions between how
things look and how they taste.
So if I give you two bottles of juice
and and they've,
they're just,
it's just water with some sugar,
a little bit of sugar in it.
One of them is lime green color died and
the other is red color dyed.
You're convinced that the rate is sweet
and the lime colored is sour,
so your eyes are overruling what your
tongue is telling you.
So there's this way in which the senses
are talking to each other and affecting
each other.
Another nice example,
my friend and collaborator,
Charles Spence and Oxford,
he gives people two bowls of yogurt and
you get these,
these bowls of yogurt and it's the same
yogurt in both bowls,
but in one of them there's a little
weight at the bottom of it,
so it's heavier.
Now I hand you the first bowl,
try that yogurt and do the second bold
try that.
You'll get which ones creamier,
rich,
thicker,
and everybody says it's the one that had
the little weight in it.
So touch the weight in your hand is
giving you a brain inflammation that it
uses to say usually something that's
creamier and thicker is a bit heavier.
So if I'm getting something heavier,
it must be creamier,
thicker.
So that's the way in which the other
senses are working to give you an
estimate of what's going on around you.
Much of our conversation thus far has
been about how the senses can be
deceived.
All those senses,
I suppose operate on detecting patterns,
consistency or differences you said,
and constant begin to be,
uh,
negate or ignored.
So,
uh,
what is initially quite interesting to
me is that sensors are our never
navigational tools for what is reality
and if our senses are to a point
unreliable or only reliable to a point,
then what is our relationship with
reality,
how it affect.
So
I think it's interesting that we often
don't know how our experiences.
We often don't realize that our,
our experience's multisensory,
you know,
people think I'm seeing now I'm hearing
and I'm touching,
but in fact as we sit here,
no,
you're looking at my face,
you're hearing my voice.
You've maybe got the residual taste of
tea or coffee in your mouth.
Those,
the smell of this room,
it's its own particular ordering.
You must know her very well.
And,
and all of that information is not
coming in separate parcels.
No ice,
no out here.
Now I touch.
It's all unified in a single conscious
experiences,
a unified view of you and the world
around,
you know,
when people have brain damage or brain
injury and you take out some of those
multisensory inputs if you remove them,
things can go wrong.
And then what gets unified as something
that seems very strange to them,
very odd.
A lot of people just after having had a
stroke,
uh,
where you know,
the,
the say their left arm is paralyzed.
They're not getting the right feedback
to know that they are ms dot paralyzed.
And some of them people who have as as
it's called,
I know sick nausea,
think that they've still got movement
with both of their hands.
And you say to somebody,
you know,
can you lift your right hand?
And the yes and they do.
Can you lift your left hand?
They say yes,
but the arm's not moving,
but they don't know it's not moving.
And so from the outside we think that's
really strange.
But what,
what the brain is doing is saying,
well,
I'm whatever signals I've got,
I'm going to try and make sense of them
in the best way I can.
And I think,
I think you see the brain's job as
putting information together and trying
to make sense of it.
You see it yourself when you're
dreaming.
So you've noticed in a dream,
really weird things happen.
You're inside,
you're outside,
you're in a car,
you're in water.
This is a man,
now it's a woman.
Uh,
I'm suddenly in a different location.
And the interesting thing is that during
the dream that doesn't seem odd at all.
You just go with it is when you wake.
You think that was very weird.
I was a bit strange.
So when you're in the dream,
you go with all those strange
distortions and a colleague of mine
said,
he thinks dreaming is the best way for
the rest of us to know what it's like to
be brain damaged,
where you're getting false and or wrong
signals from your senses,
but the brain is still trying to make
sense of them.
That's why in the dream you'll put up
with all sorts of weird things going on
and in the dream it won't seem strange.
So
the sensors are the tools by which we
determine reality.
There are various ways of disrupting our
sensual sensory experience.
Recently,
for example,
professor either go on a virtual reality
helmet is a mate of mine.
I was on in about five minutes.
I come out of that thing.
It might,
but this is all bullshit.
We really sort of affected my sense of
connection to reality.
It made me query how valid it was,
um,
to analyze that to your example of the
dream state on awakening.
I often feel this is a confection and
some of these experimental examples that
you provided or this is a nice creamy
yogurt or was tails the apocryphal or
otherwise that I've heard of,
you know,
if you spell rubbish or suddenly likely
to be more conserving here,
more pro the legal intervention.
So,
uh,
I suppose what I'm fascinated by them
and what surely must drive much of your
exploration is that to what degree is
there an objective reality?
It's so easily alterable and modified.
I think there is an objective reality.
I mean,
I'm,
I'm perfectly up for that.
It,
you know,
I'm completely up for that.
I mean,
I think,
yeah,
I think the idea that,
uh,
you know,
it's all subjective and it's all going
on in my head.
We,
the world has a habit of impressing
itself on us.
You know,
we,
we can't resist what it does.
And when you said you had the virtual
reality helmet on and it was very
convincing,
two things about one is when you get the
virtual reality helmet on,
it's pretty important that you don't
move,
that you sit still with a helmet and you
can turn your head,
that's fine.
But when people try to move around a
room,
they're getting a mismatch between the
visual flow in the virtual reality scene
and what their body is telling them
about where they are in space.
Even if there's not an object just with
their people then get really quite ill.
Um,
so,
uh,
in Disneyland,
in Paris,
when people are in this tilting a
spacecraft and they've got this
streaming of stars coming and they're in
a star wars scene,
they're going in and out of buildings
and they're moving to the side and
they're tipping upwards and backwards.
So I'm going terribly well until when
the film gets out of sequence with the
movements,
they call that Code v because people
just start vomiting as soon as they're
not getting the body feeling that the
visuals are giving them an.
That shows you why to be in touch with
reality in the right way.
Yes,
senses.
I've got to work together and they've
got to give you a lot together.
Fix.
And,
and the only thing about visual route
is,
you know,
the sense that maybe that maybe we rely
on for reality,
most is touch.
I mean if you see something and you're a
little bit doubtful about it,
you know,
think of Macbeth looking at the dagger,
is this a dagger I see before me,
but I cannot grasp it.
He wants to touch it to see if it's
real.
He's not going to take it that just
because he's,
he's,
he's leaking,
it's real.
And if people say,
Oh,
I was pretty sure there was a ghostly
figure.
Well they want to do is they want to put
their hand in it.
So our sense of touch,
even though we rely most on sight sensor
touches,
one of those,
I think gives us more confidence that we
really are connected to an objective
reality out there.
I wonder if this is underwritten by the
idea of rational materialism.
Wow.
That's a big thought.
And that unpack that for me,
a little cry fest,
but it was a beautiful little dot.
Unpack that for me a little.
Well,
Barry,
what I feel is that it really beginning
to see,
whilst you say there is an objective
reality and I certainly can't provide
any evidence that any reason it'd be
difficult for me to do that it seems
that there is a forms that are gay that
are verified more quickly.
It's difficult to query that we live in
a culture that is materialist and that
means just incentive consumerism is that
rationalism.
What can be measured,
what can be rezoned to post
enlightenment thinking governs our
times,
our politics,
our economics.
So it seems to me that the,
the US ideologically placing precedent
on I can touch it,
I can spend it,
I can fuck.
It seems to me quite animalistic and it
seems to me that given that presidents,
he's quite a political idea rather than,
well,
I can see this dagger in my mind and
perhaps other people will see daggers in
their mind and all the sides.
All right,
good,
good thought.
Let me,
let me get back to,
you know,
give us a cuddles.
Good look,
because rationalism,
as you're saying,
the kind of rational economic drivers,
especially among economists who used to
think of us as,
well,
we're rational decision makers.
You know,
we're,
we've got economic preferences and we'll
figure out what we want and you'll be
able to assess what people are more
likely to buy in,
in terms of what they believe and what
they desire.
And you'll just,
you'll just do rational decision theory,
terrible idea because we're much more
moved by our bodies and you have a
little bit of a fight back against
rationalism when you realize we're
embodied creatures and if we're paying
attention,
not just to,
you know,
our senses,
bringing information from the outside,
but say your heart.
So lovely.
Work new work by Sarah Garfinkel and
Hugo critchley in Sussex showing that
there's enormously interesting
connections between the heart and the
brain.
When every,
every time the heart beats,
it sends a signal to the brain and the
brain has got a representation of all of
its organs.
The slow waves of the stomach,
the liver,
everything.
And it's.
And it's giving you an estimate of how
things are with you.
So here's the funny thing,
some people can use that signal from
their heart to estimate how they're
doing and then that way to know their
emotions better.
So people who are good at being in tune
with how the heart's rhythm is and how
it's beating.
They feel their emotions,
their emotions more intensely,
and they're quicker and better able to
detect emotions in others.
And we often say,
if people are good at this,
we often say,
well,
there,
they've got good instincts or they're
going on gut instinct.
So we now are beginning to understand
what that might mean.
And I think that's been neglected.
And I think when you imagine in the
rational economic model that people are
going to behave in the,
um,
you know,
the most reasonable way to get what they
want given what they believe in desire.
You're leaving out the sense of from
time to time.
How are they feeling?
How anxious are they?
How,
how upset,
high relaxed I come.
And the people who really can pay
attention to that heart signal,
they're the ones who are going to be
more in tune with them and maybe less
taken in by all the attractions and the
distractions that materialistic world
throws at them.
Yes.
Because we live in a world is
overstimulating,
and just with your shampoo example,
you touched upon how I'm
necessarily mark in Hasta mislead
overstimulate over demonstrate the
capacities of certain products.
Consumerism,
in a sense,
he's built upon the idea that a product
can deliver an experience that's beyond
the rational.
Yeah.
It's all about experience.
So people in marketing no longer talk
about products.
They talk about experiences really.
And they also have this new thing which
is interesting.
They talk about we must get beyond
liking.
It's not about liking,
it's about an emotional attachment to
the product.
So if you can get somebody sort of
emotionally engaged as people are with
their equipment in a apple Mac users,
an iphone users,
they're really emotionally invested in
it.
It's not.
It's not just a that's good.
That's useful.
I like that it works.
There's an emotional attachment to it
and you might even look sniffily at
somebody sitting beside you in a cafe if
they are on a pc and not a Mac.
So,
so a lot of that is being cultured and
cultivated.
That's right.
But I think there's,
we've got to be careful because while I
think there's a lot of wow materialism
that's about misleading people,
I also think it doesn't,
it's not,
it's not harmful if we think of better
uses of,
of marketing,
not to mislead,
but to lead people to experiences that
they want and they need and that they
could,
that could be better.
Making People's food healthier,
making people eat less fat,
salt and sugar,
but not making it so horrible that they
don't want to have it,
you know,
making something delicious,
desirable,
getting them to pay attention,
slow down,
be mindful of the food they're eating.
If we can think of ways of doing that,
you might give people experiences that
were more satisfying and they'd be sated
sooner and they weren't constantly
stimulated and craving,
you know,
give me more,
give me more.
Is that unlikely that that will happen?
Because there is no imperative really
other than profit and what?
Oh,
I don't know.
I mean,
I think there's an imperative,
certainly,
uh,
when,
when you see governments are very
worried about the amount of money
they're spending on,
on,
on obesity,
they're very worried about,
uh,
you know,
health risks to people.
Now government do really is the
imperative for profit still in it.
You're in a different form.
It may be because they want them to be
healthy and be able to contribute to the
picture being ill.
No,
to contribute to the capitalist culture
at well,
enjoy life and,
and,
and work and,
and spent well,
look,
I mean all of us want to try to slow
down that cycle where we've made fruit
so hyper palatable.
It's so delicious.
It's so full of salt,
fat,
sugar that people just want it,
want it,
want it.
And also it's not surprising to see
obesity numbers grow,
especially in areas of poverty.
Now that's just not fair because,
you know,
we're,
we're advertising to people.
We're trying to get them to have these
things,
which,
you know,
a lot of companies now are,
are bad few,
but you know,
people whose lives are hard,
they're,
you know,
they're sort of left out of the great
race.
They're not feeling it's going to.
Well,
they are being encouraged just to dose
themselves with something that's
immediately gratifying.
Look at supermarket,
Look at supermarket advertising.
I think it's really pernicious.
So you've got.
You've got it really is.
I mean like you've got that thing.
I'm a taste the difference now.
What's that about?
That's about saying if you're a bit
aspirational,
I'll offer you something a little more
expensive and you will,
you will reward yourself by saying,
oh,
I was able to taste the difference.
I noticed this was better quality.
It's fine now.
So the other trying to get people to buy
something a little more it.
Which one is that?
Which,
which kind of makes sense.
Now the other thing that just,
just,
just bloody habit.
It's just habit.
It's what I'm worried about because at
the bottom end of the range,
the people that they know are not going
to pay more.
For our final question.
You're not going to be.
They've got products that they say be
good to yourself and I think that are
trainable.
Yeah,
look,
I bought donut.
Your life is.
Your life is pretty hard.
You're feeling oppressed and and hard
pushed.
You can't manage things.
How about right now?
Just a little bit of comfort.
Take that fat and salt and sugar.
I think that's a terrible thing to do to
people.
You're working in a fascinating area
because the perhaps thinking about it
now,
it seems like the most fascinating
because these,
these are the roads between reality is
one field that in reality as it is and
that the unreliability of either of
those preconditions,
what is self?
What is otherness?
The subjective and the objective and how
these two worlds a community.
How do you use that?
How does having access to this kind of
incite change your life on a daily basis
or we should changed it
for the better.
I mean,
I'm like everybody else.
I'm as vulnerable to,
you know,
to mood changes or to,
to suddenly feeling hunger or to wanting
some gratification,
but you know,
when,
when I'm thinking it through,
I'm realizing that,
you know,
if,
if things are going well inside of me,
if I'm not having bad reactions,
um,
and I,
and I feel that I'm kinda getting okay
with the people around me,
the,
and the things around me.
I must be in tune this.
This is where the subject of an object
of our gear shifted to fit each other.
That's nice,
but it often comes astray.
I mean,
people are sleeping badly.
People are eating more than they want.
People are drinking more than they want.
Um,
why is that happening?
And it's happening because of the
stresses and strains,
the,
the feeling of being left out and you
see people,
you know,
the dispossessed that cheated of
sunlight just being offered really bad
goods.
Really kind of simple,
immediate pleasures.
Now can we encourage people out of that?
You've got to get them very young.
It's got to be in schools.
It's got to be a way in which you get
people to be interested in not just a
screen or or headphones,
but,
but think of the other senses as well.
Think of the way in which you could get
kids to be interested in what they're
eating and picking out part and being
kind of,
you know,
thoughtful and,
and,
and a good at describing it and being
critical.
In France they do this little kids are
asked about the age of eight to,
to ask their parents to send them into
school with some unusual thing to eat.
Maybe an unusual fruit or an unusual
cake or whatever and the other kids are
asked to try it and they're there to
talk about it and they see,
oh,
that's interesting.
That's a bit like pineapple.
And you watch these little kids getting
fascinated because they're learning
about the foods,
but they're learning about themselves,
their own reactions.
That's getting them better in tune to
what's good for me,
not just what is everybody telling me I
should well until she'd have.
Can you sense though,
professor that places the onus on the
individual and that is this a lot like,
well,
if you want to mark it to be a better,
you should be a demand.
There's a consumer,
a recycling aisle where things are a bit
more expensive when we all know that
this is gonna be social,
it's
a social,
it's a social problem,
but we just think of we're getting
better now at thinking about social
factors that affect us.
Um,
so neuroscience used to be all about the
individual brain,
you know,
it was a very individualist sort of
discipline.
You're thinking,
you know,
what's going on in the brain of this
person and how are they reacting to the
inputs and the stimuli,
how are they likely to behave?
But now there's social neuroscience.
People are really interested in how
you're affected when having experiences
by the presence of another person.
I mean we all know if we're sitting in
front of a screen watching a film,
it's not the same experience as if we
were side by side with people around us.
If we were kind of sharing that and you
know,
setting up experiments where you're
trying to see the extent to which people
are aware of one another's reactions and
judgments and that's a,
that's a way of tuning their own being
sort of emotionally regulated,
not just by yourself but by how it's
going with other people,
how much pain I feel and how I react to
pain will be affected by whether there's
someone present in the room with me and
also whether they're a relative and
whether this is someone I take care
over,
they take care of me.
So I think there's,
there's,
there's a kind of sense in which we have
been very individual,
but we're getting better now at looking
at how socially things are organized
because these are further suggestions
that there are modifications to our
perception that are difficult to
mechanically account for.
They are difficult to mechanically
account for.
But,
but here's the other thing.
When you're making perceptual judgments,
um,
you know,
is really boring.
You're in a,
you know,
we're in a scanner and you're just
watching a set of images being flashed
up and you're asked,
is the one in the left brighter than the
one on the right or you know,
tell us which one's brighter and you're
just pressing buttons.
If you get people to do that
individually,
a,
they'll come out with a score,
how accurate they are,
but we are now looking at new research
where if people make their judgments and
express their confidence rating,
how confident were you that that you got
that right?
Seventy percent or 80 percent and then
people having done this individually are
allowed to discuss with each other what
their judgments were and to share their
confidence ratings and then you ask them
to come up with a collective decision.
Turns out that the payers are better
than the strongest of the two peers
doing it individually.
In other words,
two brains are better than one.
When you're making perceptual judgments,
if you're a light to discuss it,
you'll arrive at a better judgement if
you do it together.
Now just think of that and the
consequences that has in general that a
lot of the decision making that we go in
for probably if we were allowed to
discuss it with people,
but it's got to be discussed in a way
where,
you know,
nobody is dominating the discussion.
Nobody's taking it over to brains being
better than one is a,
is a kind of new view because it,
it,
it affects not just,
uh,
thoughts about society,
but even our perceptions,
even our perceptions might be improved
if we're light to discuss them with
people of reality itself.
I have a cool something that Eei,
he said when we spoke,
uh,
that there is no self.
We exist in dialectic.
What is reality if you're in an hour
minium,
captual drifting through space,
which I suppose is a way of physically
recreating the idea of a world stripped
of senses,
a world stripped of virtuous to
otherness.
Do you meditate?
No,
I'm a,
I do other things that get me into that
state.
So,
so here's what I don't meditate.
I'll tell you why I don't.
So I remember when I was a much younger
academic and feeling all the pressures
and very stressed and you know,
suffering all the things that high
stress will get stress.
Well,
stress because you're under pressure,
you go to publish and you've got to what
you're working on.
At this point I,
I was,
I was doing very technical philosophy of
language and logic and so it was.
And you're aware of your own science.
Very interesting.
But I was glad when I started working
on,
uh,
the connections to the sensors and
started working in psychology,
neuroscience.
It's great to collaborate.
I love collaborative work.
You're not alone.
But,
but before that,
when I was a younger academic,
philosophers often work in their own
study on their own,
having the hard thoughts having to come
up with something that's original.
That's good,
that's clear.
But under those sorts of pressures I was
getting very,
very stressed and doctors would say to
me,
I think you should meditate.
And I thought,
okay,
I'll,
I'll try that.
That may be coming down.
And then what they do is they tell you,
you know,
you're,
you're lying on the floor,
your eyes are closed,
you're very calm,
and I want you to concentrate on the
word relax.
And of course I'm a philosopher of
language and thinking the word relaxed.
It's like relax.
But it's not actually combined a relax.
And I'm starting,
my mind is just racing,
thinking about the bloody word.
So I thought,
that's no good.
That's not going to work for me.
What I need to do is turn words off.
I've got to make sure that,
you know,
I'm not having a word,
the conversations that restless internal
monologue that's going on.
So do I do that.
And for me it's always been looking at
paintings and I would,
you know,
get myself along to the national gallery
or wherever was close and I would spend
a very long time in front of a painting
until the voices in my head commenting
on it,
noting things calm down.
And there's a moment when you stop sort
of competing with what you're looking at
and you stop giving your own imposition
and you just let.
What's their come to you and then you
begin to really see what the artists or
you begin to just let a painting speak
and at that point the word SCO and it's
a lovely meditative,
calm state and I and I remain sort of
emotionless,
very peaceful in that state and it's
very interesting that I must give off
something because people who are
inclined to sort of walk in front of you
and the painting,
they sort of noticed me and they make
around the back as if not wanting to
interrupt and I think that's the nearest
I can get to kind of meditative state.
It feels very good and the body feels
very grateful.
I think in some way for being in that
state because everything has calmed
down.
The level of adrenaline has dropped.
You're not on a layer,
you're not sort of ready to react
for you.
Then it's difficult to surrender their
process of analysis and adjudication.
But as you described the process of
looking at a painting,
you seem to me that you were saying that
eventually you kind of melt into an
experience of the creator,
loss of self,
which my own experience of meditation is
somewhat about achieving sensory
experience.
Perhaps could be regarded as this
forcing one's position.
I am here.
I can smell that.
I can see that.
I can hear that if that vibrations
bouncing back at me,
it means I'm in this kind of environment
and those early example you gave of how
we react to that,
the device that makes our footsteps
louder,
it means that we continually
reevaluating the parameters of self,
what we are,
who we are.
I'm very interested in challenging the
relationship between between self and
reality because I'm curious about who
authors,
what reality is and what our role is.
We talked already of the way that
different supermarket brands would mark
it at their potential customers who is
designated in a kind of casual net crow
politics to eat the salty,
fatty foods and who can eat the lash
tasteful goods.
I'm assuming if you don't meditate,
and I have not for years,
but uh,
um,
taken psychedelics,
I wonder if you're curious about your,
uh,
with your knowledge of neuroscience,
about the,
how Oh,
mind altering substances and what they,
if what can be a.
So I think they are interesting and I
think the,
there's a lot of interest in them in the
field of psychiatry,
neuroscience at the moment now because
you get that.
Uh,
I mean,
like I,
I can,
I can remember when,
you know,
when you're hideously drunk and you're
really,
really off your face and your eyes look
one way and then when you move them you
feel the image didn't quite come with
you at the right time and things are
sort of shuddering and you see what
you're doing is breaking down the way
the sentence is normally cooperate with
each other.
And at that point you probably start to
get a dissolving of the boundaries of
the self.
But no,
no,
not in a good way.
A good way.
And I think,
I think that is interesting to see how
the self is not as some philosophers
thought indissolvable single constantly
present thing that was there.
Which philosophers think that,
well I mean Rene Descartes,
I think therefore I am.
And that self was a kind of enduring
continuing presence.
That was,
that was you.
You could take all the bits of the body
away and there would still be there
self,
which was the thinking thing and it's,
it's,
it's absolutely not like that.
I mean the way in which our sense of
self is composed of so many components
and parts that all have to be working
seamlessly together like an orchestra.
And then when they're unified you get
that probably illusion that everything
is,
is in a single unified space.
And,
and actually I think you look at people
either with psychedelic drugs or again,
under extreme conditions of drink,
or you look at people with brain damage
and you see the way in which some of
those things are breaking down and that
tells you that it's not so obvious that
that sense of self is in a permanent and
reliably always going to be there.
It's fragile.
It could be disintegrated.
It could kind of fracture and fragment.
And when you see people with brain
damage,
I think,
uh,
you know,
people who disowned a limb or people who
neglect everything on the lefthand side
of their visual field or people who
believe that they're dead.
Or people who,
who think that their relatives have been
replaced with aliens or whatever.
Those cases are often used in a very
annoying way.
Like a kind of a freak show circus where
they say,
oh look,
you know,
here's a,
here's a man who mistook his wife for a
hat.
All of that stuff.
And I think what we should say instead
when we look at people with these funny
conditions is why aren't the rest of us
not more like them?
Why is it that we don't have these weird
and funny experiences and it's you know,
there,
but for the grace of God go,
I mean if,
if anything did breakdown of some of our
systems fail to deliver what they
usually do and what we don't notice they
do.
You would get a fragmentation of the
self and we would end up in the way that
a lot of patients describe her in the
way that people who've been on lots of
our to Jen's describe so,
so,
so we,
we can be more sympathetic and more
understanding.
I think,
of other people not like us.
When we realized how much it takes to
sustain this illusion that everything is
unified and self-like and present.
Furthermore,
only a non anomalous experiences
wouldn't warrant
observation.
So we could be behaving in a way that is
collectively hysterical.
Yeah.
Without it ever causing a glitch on the
graph because it's because of.
Because of our understanding of norms.
Have you got any interest in the sort of
changing morality,
changing norms tastes the role of taste
as in like,
like this is good taste,
this is bad taste.
This is elegant,
elegant.
Yeah,
I have.
I mean I think.
I think that when you talked about
norms,
that's interesting because that which is
most familiar we think is a permanent
and has to be like that and it's only
under conditions of brain damage or or,
or an extreme or unusual anomalous
experience.
We suddenly realize,
oh my God,
it doesn't always have to be like that.
Things could change radically.
So I think the familiar is taken for
granted.
The familiar is taken as bedrock.
It'll always be like that.
This,
this is just what it is to be human and
then we realize,
you know,
slightly late and to our shame it's not
like that.
I think in terms of morals,
the something like the same issue here,
there's a lot of interest in,
in clinical neuroscience on people
who've had brain damage leading to them
behaving in some morally a porn way.
What like p two failures.
So there's a famous case,
you probably heard about the case in
Virginia where there's a man who,
who suddenly starts behaving
inappropriate to his daughter and his
wife report some and he gets sort of
banged away and he's going to be given
some remedial training,
but he's got these ptfe like thoughts,
but he's also complaining about
headaches now.
They take them in to the hospital.
They eventually scanned him and find
that he's got a huge tumor in the
prefrontal Cortex,
orbital frontal cortex here and the
operating,
the resect it,
and they take most of it out.
And then the pedophilic tendencies have
gone away.
Now the tumor hadn't completely gone
away.
It regrew and the pedophile tendencies
come back and again,
he had to be incarcerated.
Now what's really interesting about him
is that he knew it was bad to do this.
He tried to hide what he was doing and
he just,
it's.
He says,
couldn't stop himself doing it.
Now a lot of people,
lawyers get very worried about those
cases because they say,
wow,
the lowest be a defense in court saying,
you know,
my neurons made me do it.
It wasn't me golf,
but actually actually that's,
that's they don't realize that's worse
because if somebody says I couldn't help
doing it,
you're probably going to incarcerate
them and keep them locked up for the
safety of everybody around.
It's not as though they're going to walk
out of court free.
If they say I couldn't.
I couldn't help myself that they're
going to be in a restrained,
but what's interesting about his cases,
he knew it was wrong and then said,
but I had no way of controlling it.
Whereas we often tend to think of people
behaving in some morally apparent way.
They don't know the difference between
right and wrong.
That's why they do it because they don't
know the difference.
They don't realize it's wrong.
Now here's somebody who knows it's wrong
and can't stop himself doing it,
so we realize a bit more like addiction.
There's something here which we need to
separate out.
It's not enough just to have good
intentions to know what's right or
wrong.
How are you going to have the means to
be able to follow it up,
carry it out,
resist something,
not do that,
and we're relearning that.
It's a,
again,
it's an orchestration of lots of little
systems and if something goes wrong,
you're not in control of it.
You're inside of your reach is an
interesting ethical question because I
suppose it's to do with determinism and
personal foreign aid if,
if at,
because I suppose perhaps in centuries
to come that will be seen merely as a
obvious example,
an outlier of the ways that all of our
personal autonomy is being and the
written or fueled by sort of
neurological events that could be seen
as a meet urology.
Just the weather of our consciousness.
I like that.
I think it is the weather of our
conscious.
I think we're,
I think we,
we fluctuate and we're fickle.
It's not surprising therefore that
people,
uh,
are often compared to the weather,
you know,
because blue or stormy or sunny
disposition.
Yeah.
But also we're not very good.
Even though we've now got all these
satellites and we're trying to predict,
we're not very good at predicting the
weather.
Have you ever noticed when you get
weather forecasts that the first thing
someone who tells you is what happened
today?
Well,
you know,
there's was a high,
uh,
it was very high pressure and the winds
were coming in from the south and then
that led to the,
you think,
I know what happened.
I was there.
What they're trying to do is build up
your confidence that once it's happened,
they know why they can explain it and
they're hoping that that will let you
believe that they can now predict,
but things still happen in the weather
that were not predicted.
And we suddenly had a rush of snow in
the UK and boy,
nobody was expecting that.
It didn't.
I didn't hear the weather warnings about
it.
So I think people are the same.
Once somebody has,
has,
has acted.
Once they'd done something,
you can probably try and figure out why
they did it and an attribute motives.
But what we can't do is really predict
what people will do.
I mean,
we're,
we're just really not good at that.
That's why people are like the way there
we are.
We're really not able to see in advance
exactly what they'll do.
They'll have tendencies.
There'll be things that you,
you kind of expect them to do,
but I,
I like the fact that people can always
behave out of character and you can
still make sense of it is challenges,
doesn't it?
The systems of taxonomy that we put in
place that are,
these group of people are likely to
commit crimes.
These group of people that are there,
these people or be elevated and
respected because there's too much
complexity for these systems to be
reliable and these categories are
usually constructed with a particular
narrative in mind.
They are an just that phrase,
these people.
I mean,
how dangerous does that sound when you
decide that you're going to castigate a
whole group of people as though you,
you know exactly what they're like and
how they're going to behave.
Here's the terrifying thing.
The more that we get information from
neuroscience in courts,
we see pictures of brains with areas
that are lighting up and of course we
know areas don't actually.
It'll light up.
This is just sale.
Yeah,
exactly,
and it's also how we create the pictures
that demonstrate where we think travel
through language,
but the power of image and a court is
very strong.
A lot of studies going on recently with
Laura's neuroscientist showing that
courts are incredibly moved by somebody
flashing up,
you know,
an image inside a skull and here's a
little patch of activity where it seems
to be going orange and that's obviously
why somebody behaves like that's his
says.
That's exactly what it is.
And of course what the public don't know
is that that image is not a single
brain.
It's none of a single brain never is.
When you're doing scanning,
you get say 30 subjects,
your scan them all performing a task and
you scan them all when they're
performing some contrast task and what
you're looking at is a computer
representation of the average brain that
shows the average activity difference
between performing one task and another.
So that's not an individual that's a,
that's a statistical generalization.
So while you might say,
look for any 30 people,
26 of them are definitely in this
condition,
going to behave this way,
there could be the one person who who
want and who doesn't.
And I think when it comes to making
decisions about people's individual
liberty,
you're probably not wanting to go buy
well statistically.
People like this have,
you know,
re-offended or whatever it is.
There's a study that was done in a New
Mexico I think where they scanned the
brains of a longterm inmates and then
had follow ups of when they were
released,
if they were paroled and whether the
rear fender and it turned out that
getting people to perform go nogo tasks
where they're,
they're,
they're excited and ready to press a
button,
but they might go to hourly and they
might,
you know,
make an error.
People who had no impulse control or
very little impulse control,
they,
they very little activation in the
anterior singular singular cortex and
the brain,
they reoffended more often,
more reliably than people who had
greater activation and more impulse
control.
Not turned out that when the study was
done over I think a 10 year period,
the,
the neuro imaging scans gave something
like 66 percent reliable judgment about
whether someone was lightly to refund.
Whereas the parole board who are
deciding it only had a success rate of
25 percent.
Now what do we do about that?
You kinda think,
look,
I'm,
you'd want to get better than 25 percent
of your guessing.
Should we let this person out now or
early or should we let them complete the
sentence?
You want to do better than I'm 25
percent right?
That they'll,
they'll dreadfully low.
So 66 is better.
And at the same time,
again,
remember the scanning data is averaging
the result.
So you might say,
wow,
you know,
in general people with low activation
here in the ACC,
you know,
on average most of them will re offend,
but if you're the one who's not part of
that data,
a summary,
are you going to stop that guy from
being paroled?
Just because you say,
well,
on average people do so that,
that raises.
I think for society that raises huge
moral problems,
this,
this new knowledge is not neutral.
We have to make some really tough
decisions about how we use it
know so little is because of often where
funding comes from.
There's a usually a bias in that area.
The incentives and objectives of
particular institutions usually vested
interests involved.
A particular picture of reality is
usually presented and preserved.
One of the things I've learned over my
personal,
I was personally incentivized to
undertake a process of conducting these
interviews because I do a degree in
religion,
in global politics so vast,
and over the course of these interviews,
one of the things I've discovered and
I'm sort of crystallizing in my mind,
is the invisible caveat.
Unless it affects the interest of the
powerful,
we must do something about climate
change unless it affects the interests
of the powerful.
Every single conference,
that ongoing conversation,
it has this obscured never discussed
piece of information that we are driven
to conserve.
We are driven to keep institutions
invested,
interests protected.
Very seldom that they are challenged and
one of the ways I've noted that that
happens is placing a great deal of
owners on individual choice,
well,
these people have done that and that you
know,
like that rather than acknowledging the
role of states or transnational
organizations in influencing people's.
So the work that you do where in in its
complexity and understanding the
mechanics of the relationship between
Invokana as an individual and an
inverted commas.
Again,
reality seems quite vital because there
are so many modifications that are
altering what reality
is or our perception of reality.
They're not altering relative,
but they're altering our view of
reality.
We look at climate change as you said,
that's a crucial one.
The problem with climate change is not
the science.
The sciences in the science has done.
The problem is people.
There are companies,
as you say,
who do not want government into
interrupting their business and telling
them they have to reduce emissions and
telling them they'll have to do
something that,
that,
that threatens their profits.
So that's our problem.
How do we do with the people?
That's the issue.
It's not one more paper.
One more piece of evidence is actually
going to convince anyone.
It's how do you deal with those sort of
political agents of change?
How do you hide?
You Hide,
you monopolize that.
How do you get people on site to do
that?
That wonder.
I wonder that too,
but
it doesn't seem to be with rational
information because as you said,
the affirmation is,
yeah,
it seems like it would need to be where
power is,
needs to alter as long as power.
The ability to influence remains with
people that are in profit rather than a
large number of people as long as power
is not disseminating.
So that will be careful with the talk of
power.
I mean,
I know people will often just sort of
reached for the word,
but I,
you know,
I remember Tony Benn always saying,
uh,
if people have power,
where did they get it?
Who gave it to them?
How do they use it often and yeah,
and how they use it.
Right?
So,
so,
so now you begin to see we've got to
look at those stages.
You've got to look at power wasn't just
in a,
suddenly it was there and it was
exercised.
There had to be people who were,
uh,
agents of,
you know,
acquiring it and others who gave,
gave in and seeded and said,
you can have this power and I'm,
I'm happy to grant it to you.
So that's where those individual
decisions and those,
those judgments and those influences
come in and they need to be looked at
really carefully.
What fascinates me is that how much work
goes into concealing power.
We now sort of live in a time where it's
like,
well,
where is this power now?
If,
if,
if democracy at the level of the state
seems to be retained within quite
limited borders.
It's difficult to access transnational
corporations that they know that we
purport to live by rationalism,
but a rational decision on discovering
that climate change is real and can only
be effected if agriculture altars in
this way and if energy and power
companies or in this way.
As soon as you know that,
where is the resistance?
And as soon as you could determine it,
other,
he's here
until you have purchase in that area.
It's irrelevance.
No point in telling people,
put your bottles in this Bin and that
bin.
But it's never a good telling people
what to what to do.
They often don't mean think a thing of,
I know more about his food and health
issues,
people telling them,
telling others what to eat,
what not to eat,
what's good for you,
what's bad for you,
try to keep away from these particular
types of food and so on.
It never works.
So what you've got to do is incentivize
people in some other way.
And with food it's always deliciousness.
Deliciousness will win out.
It doesn't matter whether you tell
people you know this is the healthy
option and that's the unhealthy option.
They'll eat what they prefer and what
they find delicious.
But remember,
as you're trying to get messages across
about how you can find delicious food,
if it's Vegan or vegetarian,
I mean a lot of people becoming Vegan
and a lot of people resisting it because
they think,
well,
the food won't be so delicious.
So then we've got to make delicious
Vegan food.
If you're going to actually convert
people to say,
you know,
you give up lots of,
uh,
heads of cattle,
which are very expensive to be.
If we can make something so delicious
that you don't mind doing it,
that's the thing rather than the moral
argument.
Some people are very principled,
some people are very moral,
they'll do it,
but we'll move them.
But remember,
as you try to get people to eat better,
you try to get people to have better
experiences.
You're up against multinational
companies who are fantastically good,
who've got lots of research arms.
They are to find out how to grab people.
If you look at mark,
uh,
just jacket norris extra cars,
shanker's book,
the Dorito effect.
It's fantastic when you see just how
much work goes into making a Dorito so
much more delicious and desirable than
any other food from the,
from the luke of the bag,
from the feel of the bag from the moment
you open it from the order that comes up
from the slight spiciness on your tongue
and everything else.
Multinational companies are doing a lot
to get you to engage with that product,
so it's going to be a very hard fight
and the way you're gonna be able to sort
of wean people off things that are easy,
cheaper,
a desirable and delicious to something
that's healthy is not telling them it's
healthy.
You just got to make better stuff.
You're going to make things that will
actually move them at the gut level,
at the,
at the smell and taste and the look and
feel,
or perhaps even beyond that gut level.
Because if as soon as system in that,
if I may say that the suggestion that
people will only act,
at least in this example on the basis of
self interest of deliciousness,
the experience of deliciousness is
there.
Not a moral equivalent to the delicious
as sense of beauty,
of connection,
of gut shot and fraternity for sure,
but I wonder how we access the access
that you've got to have time and
patience and a certain amount of
leisure.
I mean the people who pay a lot of
attention to but you have got rather
comfortable lives and an ability to sort
of take time out and stop and be mindful
and thoughtful about what they're
interacting with and we,
we didn't pick up on a point that you
raised but we can come back to that just
briefly on matters of taste.
So it used to be that the way that you
influence society was the idea of seeing
that's very bad taste to,
you know,
to watch this television show or it's
very bad taste to,
to eat this thing or is there any,
you know,
it's very naf to have pineapples stakes
with,
you know,
I'm a gammon stakes with a pineapple
ring on it.
The Cherry on the top,
you're very knife let's,
let's aspire to something else.
But,
but that was often those ideas of tastes
and what people wanted to identify with.
We're often in a dictated by people who
had a,
a kind of elite position who were
frightening others into saying,
if you're not like,
as you know you're,
you're not really making it.
But I do think what we eat,
what we do with our leisure time,
what we,
uh,
what we drink,
how we,
how we spend any spare money that's all
about who we want to identify with it
is.
It is a kind of identity thing and,
and some very nice entity and otherness,
identity and otherness.
Louise excluded in this group who's not
choosing what I do,
who's making an apple.
Yeah.
You know,
one of us prawn cocktail really,
you know,
so that,
that sense of wanting to identify.
It's very powerful and it,
and it does come through food and
clothing and music and all the rest of
it.
And politically there's a,
there's an angle here because once
you've decided who you identify with,
when decisions come along that you
haven't thought through,
it's much easier to say,
well,
who did it?
My,
what did the group identify with?
Tend to say,
oh,
I'll go with that.
And you're seeing more and more of that
in social media.
And I the fact that having already
decided who you belong to,
if there's an issue and you haven't made
up your mind if your group,
if your people decide one way,
it's very easy to tag yourself on the
back of that,
but no,
we are starting to get islands or people
separated from each other because you're
talking to the people who are.
You're identifying with a not
necessarily engaging with and listening
to the others,
and of course will make better
decisions.
Although it's uncomfortable if we have
more diversity of opinion,
we've got more.
People are kind of challenging.
It's almost like we don't have geo
tribes.
Now we have an atomized online opinion
groups to return to a point about beauty
there for a moment,
if you think of it from an artistic
perspective,
specifically the keats quote,
beauty is truth.
Truth is beauty.
That beauty is value is only in that it
is an Avatar of goodness rightness.
So I don't mean,
but in terms of other,
of course I do.
And in terms of aesthetics and perhaps
Oscar Wilde is a good vehicle for this,
can you think of sort of like wild
initially superficial seeming sense of
aesthetics?
Uh,
on examination it seems that Wilde was
particularly interested in truth,
purity,
innocence,
like,
so some charming ideas around
Catholicism in these,
right in about children.
So like,
you know,
again,
when we talk about the senses,
it seems that there are ways of dialing
up,
dialing down in the bowl of yogurt,
you know,
optical illusions that we,
even when you see them in a tabloid
newspaper sort of dazzle you.
When I was a kid,
there were these things that seemed
three d when you're standing,
it's like a dinosaur was coming out.
And like,
I'm always fascinated by that because
there's something of,
I guess what Freud would call the
uncanny.
There've been moments I've had with
psychedelics when I think reality is not
what I think it is.
And this is just but one bandwidth and
talk for a moment of,
uh,
you know,
the,
of course,
we live within a limited spectrum of
color.
We live within a limited range of sound
vibration.
Is it a,
is it pointless to speculate,
but we.
There are realms of senses for which we
do not have the instruments that we're
surrounded by waves and all or his
lights and fields for things for which
we don't even have the language because
we don't have the instruments to receive
them.
Well,
we could think that,
but I actually,
I'm,
I'm more intrigued by the idea that,
that we're already in receipt of so many
sensory inputs that we don't pay
attention to it we don't know about,
but we're influenced by them.
The fact that we are not aware of them
doesn't mean they're not shaping our
experience conditioning what we're
about,
but here's another thing that to go back
to beauty,
which I think links with the political
in a way that might interest you.
We all operate a kind of everyday
aesthetics.
We choose which Mug to have in which
ball.
When we're having our breakfast,
we like things arranged a certain way.
We will make little efforts to make our
surroundings feel more pleasing,
happier,
and it's,
I think,
a terrible sign of the poverty of the
spirit when people are really crushed
when they no longer even do that.
So there was a sociologist in Glasgow in
the seventies who went and lived in the
Gorbals uh,
and she had to kind of manufacture an
accent so people didn't treat her as an
outsider.
She wanted to do anthropology,
you know,
I'll be among the people.
Yeah.
And I'm going to
exactly.
Okay.
So she was able to sort of see roughly
fake,
but like an anthropologist,
I'm going to go and brilliant and she.
But she said it always struck me.
She said the people I was living amongst
who were most deprived didn't even make
any effort to make their immediate
surroundings prettier or pleasant.
Other people,
it put a painter Cota and on the door
they'd have a plant part outside the
window.
There are ways in which they just wanted
to make their environment a little
nicer.
And then you saw people who couldn't
even do that.
They were so broken.
They were so crushed.
They were so beaten down that even that
attempt just to make your immediate
surroundings feel more pleasing had
gone,
so I think that urge to have a little
bit of everyday aesthetics to make our
surroundings nicer,
to make a choice,
a choice about what,
what,
what spoon.
We'll use what Mug we'll use,
what you know,
how will we just want things to look on
the table.
That's very basic about being okay about
wellbeing and about humanity and when
that goes,
we're really in trouble in a few things.
I'd like to pick up like a technique for
people in addiction for measuring your
wellness and sort of a personal wellness
index where you can sort of ask yourself
a series of questions and give yourself
a one to 10 evaluation on how clean is
your car at the moment.
How well is your diet?
How often are you arguing with your
spouse?
These sort of tiny.
When I think myself,
there've been times in my life where I
would almost eat the cereal out of box.
Typically tippecanoe chew now into Udl
because I've got.
I've got no demonstration of
selflessness,
no idea of the beauty of the self,
you know,
the idea of the beauty of the world.
Yeah.
There's,
those values have totally broken down.
And also I'm Grayson Perry and he's
brilliant documentaries about taste and
class where he sort of,
what he,
uh,
like he's,
I suppose he's thesis was that like are
the higher up the class,
the less demonstrative class structure
that less demonstrative taste was in
working class culture,
big Larry vehicles with staff on them,
jewelry,
tatters.
And then when you get into the upper
class,
upper class is sort of everything
understated no labels in the middle
class.
It was a wonderful way of tracking class
when,
how classes exemplified and further on,
tasty sort of showed like there's a clip
of warm metal work in men's club,
sort of at the front with some kind of a
crooner guy and she was all drunk and
having a wonderful emotional experience
and crying.
And he said like,
but why do we think of that as somehow
sort of vulgar?
Whereas a woman generally weeping in a
box at lover him,
we think of the height of
sophistication,
who is deciding what is beautiful,
who is deciding what is good tastes.
Very often it's about distance,
isn't it?
A lot of people when they consider the
high arts at the fine arts,
they,
they want to embrace it,
but they want a kind of distance from
it.
So I think our prayers like that.
It's so staged.
It's so artificial that you know you can
exercise those emotions,
but only because it's clearly not
reality and it's a little bit further
away.
Whereas the crooner in the club,
she's getting very near to kind of
affecting you.
This is her real life.
It's probably some of the sadness in her
life that you're immediately hearing and
that way in which some people like art
to be a safe space to exercise their
emotions.
As long as there's a bit distant from
them,
it's not going to.
It's not going to be bad to have
tragedy.
something side.
It's not going to be bad to have
something that's kind of powerful.
That's also as a skirt.
I think I can say that a
characteristically English thing to want
to do a certain level of society.
Yeah,
we,
we're living,
we're aloof.
You don't want your feelings and there.
I mean,
Scott's very funny because they imagine
they're full of reason,
but they're actually full of passion and
you know,
they get,
they get very wound up and worked up so
they feel the strain between those two.
But I think,
you know,
the English often volume,
the lack of overt expression of emotions
and yet we'll still go to an opera and
weep in a,
as long as it's in a safe space,
as long as it's not,
you're not going to have to get up and
talk to your neighbor immediately beside
you when you were feeling a little raw
and emotional.
So I think that's right.
And I think also that expression of
exercising your taste again,
um,
people with terminal illnesses who've
got limited periods of time,
they often say they know,
pay attention to their everyday
experience and to the pattern of it.
The texture of it and a new way,
you know,
they instead of just putting the milk
bottle on the table,
they'll put it into a jug.
They'll want to sort of pour it on the
on the cereal.
Why make that effort?
You might say,
you know,
you only have to wash out the drug
because it makes that particular moment
nicer.
Brighter.
I'm looking after myself.
I'm taking care of each of these moments
because they're precious and if we had
endless amount of time to live,
nothing will be precious because we
could always do it later.
We can always do it at some other moment
and I think it's being in the moment,
being aware of how you make the
immediate environment and the
environment of others better.
That's the thing that we want to
concentrate on.
That's the thing that makes me feel
good.
Live.
Yes.
To create somehow a kind of art
throughout life to be reverential
towards beauty,
our our own beauty in the beauty of
others and that the senses can be
instruments for measuring beauty.
Not Tools,
tools,
but ways in which we remediate the
beauty in ourselves and others.
And actually are really literally in
touch with it.
Yeah,
I think so.
Literally in touch.
This is where the external world is
entering our lives through these fields,
through the portals.
This is where we access.
That's very beautiful.
Just darkness and possibly a lighter
note though,
it may not be your like a connoisseur of
wine.
You must be bloody good at that.
Ah,
God,
I always terrified of this question
because the one thing that people who
are pretty good tasters and pretty
knowledge about wine as,
they never want to say that they're
experts because they're also very easily
fooled.
It's from Tesco because it's two 99.
Oh,
I found this delicious tasting a belief
in a barrel.
That's.
I remember.
Here's a nice story about,
about wine experts that I think is,
is better.
Uh,
I talked to German who was a uh,
uh,
the world,
Somalia.
He won the championship world some lea.
So there he is looking after people in a
restaurant with wines and he said,
what do you think you need to be a good
Somalia?
He said,
you probably imagined someone who can
taste any wine and tell you immediately
where it came from and who's venyard and
what year or you think you're someone.
It's someone who will tell you,
Oh,
you know,
Sarah Motto,
if this is what you're reading,
this is what you should drink.
He said,
what you need is humility.
You need modesty and humility.
He said,
because your job is to try to find out
what the customer likes and wants and to
help them to find something that's right
for them and good for them.
And he said,
and also,
you know,
every day of the week I'll have to blind
taste and I will get a wine wrong.
You know,
it will make me humble again.
Don't make me no.
I still don't understand everything
about this world of wine.
And he talked about having a client who
came in to the restaurant,
guy knew nothing about wine.
Your does a a steak dish.
And he picks up the wine list and he
goes through it and he finds a dessert
wine,
Chateau de cam,
perhaps one of the world's most
expensive,
most beautiful wines.
But it's a,
it's a sweet dessert wine and,
and he,
he,
he either knows the name or he's looking
for an expensive wine,
so he says,
I'll have this,
and the smelly lea didn't say,
Oh sir,
no,
you don't have a dessert wine with the
state.
You want something from the Rhone or
from Bordeaux and let me find it for
instead he came,
he went to the sheriff and he came back
and he said to the guy,
since you're having the Chateau de cam,
the chef thought that you might want it
with a for grass source.
So they had changed the food to make
something more acceptable,
more suitable to go with the wine he had
ordered and he said,
and that guy now trusts me and he's
learning more and he's becoming quite
enthusiastic and you know,
he lost my advice and I think that's a
lovely story.
Didn't humiliate him.
He didn't show off.
We didn't sort of impose his knowledge.
He find out what this guy wanted and
what it was about.
And then showed him gradually found ways
to show how do you match food and wines.
And that's what I always want to do,
if I'm,
if I'm trying to get people interested
in wine,
I do not want to do that thing that so
often we see where someone's standing at
the front of the room and they're
saying,
well,
this is a particularly tight knit,
Clara it from the left bank.
I think your show,
it's,
uh,
I think you'll find it's showing a
little bit of maturation,
you know,
very fantastic.
And everybody in the room thinks I don't
know what he's talking about.
I don't get that and I'll never get
that.
And they feel left out.
So instead I think what I always want to
do is give people a chance to discover
something about themselves while they're
having a wine.
So the hardest thing people do is,
is getting a single glass and you see
how is it?
And they say,
oh,
I don't know.
I like it,
I don't like it.
But you see,
can you say anymore?
No.
But now if you give people two glasses
of wine,
two glasses of different lines,
you said try them both.
Which do you prefer?
I prefer the one on the right.
Is it different from the one that left?
Yeah.
Hi.
Different.
Oh,
well.
It's slightly more juicy or fruity or
it's slightly more sour or the one is
light sour inside.
Now they start comparing and now they're
beginning to understand something about
what's going on in the wine and also
something about what's going on in them
and I love that because then when they
learn about it,
they'll go and pass it onto someone
else.
They'll get someone else to practice and
to try this and you say,
with our red wine,
what do you think of it?
Or describe it.
They'll say,
well,
it's fruity and you can say,
okay,
red fruits are black fruits and that's
kind of an easy thing for people to
think,
is it more blackberry black currant or
is it strawberry raspberry?
They can do that and now you just give
them choices and you get them to explore
and either exploring not just the wine.
They're exploring their response and
reaction to it and you find out what
they like and what they don't like and
now they can choose better than they
can,
you know,
they can now take an interest,
they can go on and exploring for
themselves.
And that's what I want to do.
I want,
I want to give people the means to do
that
quite early in that I realized that I'm
an alcoholic.
No one do that to take,
to take black fruit.
Red Fruit actually.
Typically,
what are you doing?
That's fantastic.
I think that was a,
um,
a beautiful analogy for the world of
knowledge in general that we have to
invite people to have a degree of
authority in their experience of sensual
world and the philosophical world.
And again,
only the things that there are words
for,
uh,
being described when you were talking
about one there.
My wife wrote this brilliant book when
we're before our daughter was born and
they in this book,
it was really excellent skill.
It said it gave you the vocabulary for
describing the types of sensation you
would go through him.
Birth.
Is it burning?
Is it stretching is in actually in sort
of when it broke down the pain,
it took away works that were very
generic and also catastrophic and
provided you with a means to articulate
what your experience is,
you that moment,
and I think my wife certainly said it
removed much of the fear around that
probably became a connoisseur of her own
pain.
She was interested in it.
What was it like?
Was it stinging?
Was at burning?
Was it stretching?
Is it pulling in Sun and,
and the more she's attending and
thinking about the particular texture
the last year,
just feeling the raw yuck of pain,
the more you're able to cope and pain
management is often about that.
Getting people to actually pay attention
to the,
you know,
the real we've and fabric and texture.
Do you think that neurologically that's
because moving you to a different part
of your consciousness and possibly
remove brain and uh,
and limiting distractions?
Yeah,
it is,
but it's better to do that than just
sedate you.
Have you kind of comatose.
I mean,
I,
I really think pain management is
difficult but,
but more attention rather than less.
And more discrimination rather than
less.
You'll be able to manage it.
Yes.
Oh,
well,
Professor Barry Smith.
Thank you so much.
That was a really interesting and quite
intense journey.
I thought.
Wide ranging.
It was a pleasure.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Thank you for your time.
It's brilliant.
That show was sponsored by my book
recovery,
which is available now on Amazon.
Six quid on a bargain price while way to
get your head straight in January.
Look at the world.
Everyone's addicted to their phones.
Everyone's addicted to everything.
The world is falling apart.
What is the solution I am finally.
If you like this show,
please subscribe and review in Itunes or
the one that's on android phones and do
give it five stars please.
I can't justify it,
but hopefully the quality of the product
speaks for itself,
but even if it doesn't,
why don't you speak.
Thanks guys.
Hope you enjoyed the show.
Bye.